So,
good morning, everyone. I'm Barbara Pistilli, medical
oncologist at Gustave Roussy, France.
And I'm truly pleased to welcome you today to
this Dharma Master Jian Tai Symposium in Biomarkers,
Next Generation Tools for ADC, Defining
Biomarkers of Response through Technological
Innovation.
And
so the main topics that we are going to discuss
in this symposium are, first of all, how we can
measure the target expression in a more reproducible way.
Second point, how we can include the computational
pathology, and particularly also the multimodal frameworks
in the generation of more accurate
biomarkers for predicting the response to the ADC.
And finally, there is also the clinical perspective that will be my
perspective, and in which I will discuss how we
can move the ADC biomarkers from the
exploratory setting in which we are right now to a more
validated biomarkers that we can use in our clinical
practice to provide a more accurate selection of ADC
for each patient.
I'm really pleased to share this session
with an outstanding panel,
Professor David Reim, that is Professor of Pathology and of
Medicine at Yale School.
And Professor Reim is also the
lead of a lab that has already produced
different type of quantitative approaches for measuring
target expression, but also different new
technology for the prediction of response to multiple targeted
therapy and immunotherapy. And then Professor Maria
Bakolopoulou, that is Assistant Professor in Applied
Mathematics at CentraleSupélec, France,
University of Paris-Saclay. And Maria's
main research interest is in
the development of computational methods for image perception,
focusing on medical application.
I would like also
to remind that this session is named in honor
of Dharma Master Jian Tai,
and through the support of an endowment.
Dharma Master Jian Tai was a brave young abbess
who dedicated her life to Dharma teaching.
She was a never smoker, who was diagnosed with lung cancer.
Although not available to her at the time, targeted
treatments are now available for the mutation that was
identified in Dharma Master Jian Tai's cancer.
According to her wishes and the memory of Dharma Master
Jian Tai, her family established an
endowment to support the Dharma Master Jian Tai
Advances in Lung Cancer Research session, Dharma
Master Jian Tai Symposium in Targeted Therapy, and Dharma
Master Jian Tai Symposium in Biomarkers, like the one of
today.
The family's goal
is to foster cancer research
that leads to new drug development so that patients with
cancer will live longer, have better quality of life,
and potentially reach a cure in select cases.
So thank you very much, and I would like to introduce the first
speaker, Professor Reim.
Okay, I'd like to start up by thanking the organizers for inviting
me to give this session today. And what I'm going to talk about today
is
bringing quantification to pathology in the context of
determining which ADCs patients should receive.
These are my disclosures, and I would note that
it's important to note that some of these disclosures are financial support from my
lab, and in fact, we have mutual interests with many pharma and biotech
companies. And as you can see,
much of the work I'm going to discuss today has been funded by biotech.
We'll talk about the conventional pathology and immunohistochemistry with
chromagens. That is what we do today.
And then a quantitative approach with a low CV, since the
conventional approach has quite a high coefficient of variation.
Then I want to talk about selective biomarkers, which is, I think,
a new class of biomarkers that will be really important as more and
more drugs are approved in the same setting. And then finally, some next steps.
So there's the guy that started it. This is Clive Taylor.
And the story goes that he wanted to look at a particular
protein on a tissue slide, and so he did what we now call
immunofluorescence. And he brought it over to his mentor, and his mentor said,
"Yeah, Clive, this is great, but I can't see the surrounding tissue.
I need the context." So Clive went back and learned how to
use chromagens and began what we now know as immunohistochemistry, which is
chromagenic. And in fact, this was back in 1974 that this
occurred, and you can see that's sort of the timeline of changes in
immunohistochemistry since then.
Heat-induced antigen retrieval, polymer-based amplification, et cetera.
And this is what it was designed for.
It was designed for telling whether something is or is not expressing a protein,
not on a binary level. So if it's p63 positive,
it's a squamous cell carcinoma and TTF-1 negative.
If it's TTF-1 positive, then it's an adenocarcinoma, and it helps to
see all some synapsin staining. And if it's chromogranin positive,
then you can call it a small cell, but these are chromogranin negative.
And that's what IHC was designed for, and in fact, has been used for
pretty much. But then what happened is that we decided that we would use it in a
continuous basis and try to use it to score or assess levels.
And so this was the original score, zero, one, two, three, and
then to many more. This shows you two
things, that you can still see that binary event between positive and
not too positive or negative.
But then what happened is we tried to splice this
or-Stagger this and make this way more granular
than the technology is capable of with the new
anti-HER2 ADCs, where we had to separate zero from one.
Can we do that?
Well, here's the ASCO/CAP guidelines for how we're supposed to
score. And the ASCO/CAP, in their wisdom, called both zero and one
negative, because the assay was tell the positives from the negatives, and there
was even a special trick called fish for the equivocales that you
could use to mediate. But there's no trick to get zeros from
ones. And in fact, the ASCO/CAP and the
leaders of that organization didn't think that we could tell those apart.
But now we have to, as zeros get no ADC
and one plus gets trastuzumab drugs Tecan.
So can you tell them apart? This is from the guidelines that they give to
pathologists to learn how to do this.
And this is
from Pathway, a Roche Ventana pathway, anti-HER2 antibody
4B5 that I'm going to show a little bit later as well.
And this is an IHC, either one or zero.
And here's the other one, either a one or zero. I'll go back and forth a few times.
This is a one or zero. This is a one or zero.
Now, I realize there might not be a lot of pathologists in the audience, but even
if there were,
I think that this is impossible. I can't tell them apart, and I can't tell them
apart with any kind of reproducibility.
So we asked the question, can real pathologists in the real world tell them apart?
So we took 118 pathologists from multiple institutions around the country,
all
sign-out pathologists, that is, people in clinical practice.
And we showed them 170 cases of breast cancer stained with
IHC for HER2.
You can see if you're pathologist number one, 45 or 45% of the
patients don't qualify for T-DXd.
But if you're pathologist number 18, only 15% of the patients don't qualify.
So the patient gets drugged on the basis of their pathologist.
I don't think that should happen. I think it should be on the basis of their tumor.
And overall, we found a concordance of only around 29% or
30% if you looked at just zero versus one.
So it's not just us. A study in Japan was done with
144 pathologists on 20 cases. Their overall agreement was
63%. A study was done in Australia, nine pathologists with 60
cases. Their overall agreement was 80%.
And the best study done by 77 pathologists in Europe, led by
Joe Rusoff and Beppe Viale, showed that for the zeros and
ones, they could get around 82% concordance or 81%
concordance. And they could train.
They said, "Oh, we'll just need to train the pathologists how to do this." Well,
training doesn't work. You can't train a pathologist to do this any more than
you can train me to fly when I jump off the stage. It's not humanly possible.
And that's what they showed here, that there was no difference before and after
training. No significant difference before and after training.
You'll note one thing, that for the positives, we're really good at that.
That's what the assay was designed for.
So we can tell the threes from the not threes, but we're not so good at telling the
zeros from the ones. So is 80% good enough?
Well, if I'm the patient, it's not. How do we do with biomarkers in other spaces?
So this is EGFR mutation in lung cancer.
This was done by 10 different groups 10 times and repeated
with different operators, different instruments, and different days.
And the average agreement is 99%. That's what patients
deserve. And so we need to
up our game a little bit, level up, as our kids say,
to get to the point where we can have at least an agreement of
95%, if not 99%.
So just a little nomenclature. I'm going to talk about reading.
That's what pathologists do. It's the subjective but expert interpretation of
information on a histology slide and measurement, the quantitative
objective determination of amounts or concentrations on a
histopathology slide.
How do we do that? Well, reading we talked about. That's the pathologist's opinion.
And you saw that that can pretty much be around the 80 percentile for this
particular question. For other questions, like how much immune cells there
are in lung cancer in immunotherapy
candidate patients, the agreement is closer to 50%.
So reading is not a great way to assess protein
concentration on slides. One way we could do it is circle the region of interest
and just look at the intensity of the chromagen. And that's actually been done.
But the chromagens are not linear and they're almost binary and they're not
reproducible, and we'll talk about that in a minute.
And the other way is to phenotype and count.
So you can segment, find the cells with human intervention, teach software to find
the cells, and then count the cells that are positive.
But again, you're using a positive-negative threshold, which is binary, and that's
not how biology works. Biology is a continuous platform,
continuous expression of various proteins and other
biomolecules. And so the best way, in my opinion, to do it is measurement, and
measurement is intensity divided by area.
So to illustrate this, this is a made-up slide of a patient with
various cells at various gray intensities.
If your cutoff is zero gray intensity, then you only have three of those.
But if your cutoff is 15, then you'd have 50% positive.
But if your cutoff is 35%, you'd have 30% positive.
So this isn't a great way to score. We built a
semi-continuous scoring system called the H-score, which is a
continuous method for analysis of IHC, where you have the
ordinal score times the percentage of cells that show that ordinal score.
This is from McCarty in 1994. But the problem is that if the
intensity is a little different or the judgment is a little different, you'll be
off by a factor of two or three or even more.
And this is actually a proof of that. This is a paper from David Dobbs et al.
that just was published in "Lancet." And each one of these dots represents a
different CLIA lab, mostly in Europe.
And so if you're this lab, your lower limit of detection is about
30,000
molecules per cell. But if you're this lab, you can't detect anything less than
90,000. So these are all CLIA labs that are certified labs,
and they're all using the test exactly according to the label, the FDA protocol
for this. And they're still variable over a scale of almost a half an
order of magnitude or more than that, three times.
And so this is why I don't think chromagen should be used for quantification, is
that we're just not reproducible for chromagens.So what we
can do is we can make a quantitative assay, but we're going to have to jump to
fluorescence. So how do we do that?
Well, this is a summary slide of all the things.
We start with a cell line array. These are all cell lines that have had the amount
of protein determined by mass spec, and then the area determined.
So the
mass spec gives us attomoles per microgram, and then we can convert
that to attomoles per square millimeter by assessing the area of each
cell and then putting that together into a standard curve, just like
college biochemistry. And we can have the attomoles per millimeter on this
side and then the signal on this side. How do we get the signal?
Well, we do quantitative fluorescence, just like immunohistochemistry, but with
fluorophores and tyramide signal amplification.
So we can look at the fluorescent signal only within the cytokeratin-positive
pixels. Cytokeratin-positive pixels gives us the area, and the sum of
the intensity is our average Q score, which can then be converted to an attomoles
per square millimeter. It turns out we can't just directly compare the
attomoles because different biologic targets have different levels.
So what we propose to do is compare the percentiles in a
population. And this is the work of Jack Robinson in my lab, and
others.
Here's how it works in the actual CLIA lab.
We have a CLIA lab called Quantitative Diagnostics and Anatomic Pathology.
So you can send us your slide, and we'll batch stain it with up to nine
slides per tray. There's 10 slide tray holders in the Leica bond,
and one of those slides is going to be that cell line control.
So one cell line control for every tray.
Maybe someday we'll put one on every slide, but right now one per 10 is about where
we're working. The biopsies scanned in attomoles per square millimeter are
calculated in the background. Then a critical piece happens.
The pathologist circles the critical part.
But the pathologist doesn't usually read fluorescence, so we've computationally
converted the fluorescent image into something that looks like a conventional
DAB-based or chromogen-based IHC.
And then the pathologist can circle the region of interest, thereby not measuring
normal ducts or stroma that has no epithelium in it and
leading to a more accurate measurement, and also giving the pathologist confidence
that what they're measuring is actually what they're supposed to be measuring, that
is, the malignant tumor. You can see the weakness of this technology is
illustrated here. The level of HER2 in this region of the
slide is different than the risk level in this region of the slide, and that's
inherent heterogeneity. And we haven't figured that out yet.
We're working on it, but we haven't figured that out yet.
So for now, we just average across the entire section.
When you do that, you get a result like this.
This is 316 core biopsies from breast cancer patients actually seen
in our clinic between 2022 and 2023.
And this was the IHC score that resulted in them getting trastuzumab or not and
getting them categorized by what type of therapy they would get.
And you can see the three
pluses and two plus amplifies, the reds and oranges are all pretty much on the top.
We're good at that. But we're not so good at the lows.
The zeroes are green, and the one pluses are blue.
And you can see that they're essentially interchangeable on the bottom level of the
scale. This is actually now published, and I'll show you the
publication in a minute. But if you do two at once, you can see an
interesting thing, an almost inverse relationship between
Trop-2 and HER2. And so the patients with low Trop-2
are down here, but they have high HER2, and then there's patients
with high Trop-2 and low HER2 down over here.
How accurate is the assay? Well, it's a CLIA lab assay, and it's an analytic assay,
so we can actually calculate the LOD and the LOQ, limit of detection and limit of
quantification. And we can calculate the CV, both inter-assay,
three days with a minimum of a week washout, three different days, or intra-assay
with different operators and different trays of the Leica bond, and they're all
below 10%. So this assay is now New
York State Department of Health approved and approved in our CLIA lab at Yale, and
we're working on licensing the assay so it can be used more broadly than just in
my little QDAT lab.
This is the publication of the prospective assessment that was published in
"Laboratory Investigation." And this is how the assay is built.
It's now open source, and all the software associated with it is open
source downloadable on GitHub.
So the next step is selective markers, and I think selective markers are really the
strength of measurement. Because ultimately, we know that there's
a diagnostic biomarker. I showed you that in the beginning.
That's what Clive Taylor invented.
Then there's prognostic biomarkers, and there aren't many of those.
But
perhaps the best example is Oncotype. That can tell you who does not need drug.
So prognostic markers say that the standard of care is good enough.
And so we won't see those from pharma companies anytime soon.
But the predictive markers are what the pharma companies have brought to us.
And each one, the clinical trial, a predictive marker is a companion
diagnostic. But I think what we need is beyond that.
I would argue that we need a selective biomarker now.
In fact, selective biomarkers have been around.
That's when you do a 400-gene panel.
You're selecting which gene mutation is present and which drug you should give on
the basis of that mutation. I believe it's time to move that to protein,
but it's harder in protein because you have to measure it with a low CV.
So there's about 260 known antigens being clinically tested, and when I
presented this a couple of days ago, someone told me, "No, there's 400." So there's
a lot either way. There's a lot of ADCs in clinical trials, which mean
soon there will be multiple targets for the same clinical setting.
In fact, there already is in advanced breast cancer.
You can get either a cetuximab govitecan or trastuzumab
deruxtecan in advanced second-line setting.
So how do you know which one to give first?
Well, I would argue this is what you should do.
You should measure in attomoles per square millimeter, both HER2 and
Trop-2, then proportion them in the population.
And this patient would get T-DXd first because they are relatively low
Trop-2 and much higher
HER2, even though the actual attomoles per square millimeter aren't that much
different.
This is what the plot looks like and the inverse relationship that I think is
really important that will be generalizable, and I'll show more of this later
on in the talk. But in each case, you standardize them.
So you can have attomoles on each axis and then have each
patient represent a dot and figure out where your patient is in the
scatter plot in order to decide which drug to give
first.So does it work? Well, we're still in
the process of proving that. This is a preliminary retrospective study that we've
done at Yale with 65 cases, which isn't very much.
All received T-DXd in the second-line or higher setting, and they were
all run by the Troplex assay to measure Trop-2 and HER2 on each
case. And this is what we found, that most of the three pluses are up here, as
you'd expect, but there's occasionally a fair number of two pluses down here in a
relatively low range, and then the zeros and ones.
Surprisingly, there's some zeros and ones even in the pretty high range, which we
don't completely understand yet
other than it might be that the IHC
is not so good on really small pieces of tissue, which is what you have on a small
biopsy in the metastatic setting.
Well, here, with only 65, we just divided the population of HER2
positive
or HER2 animals per square millimeter at the median, and you can see
that the high levels above the median has a 12.8-month median
time to next treatment compared to the low levels, only a
7.5-month time to next treatment.
So we just finished and haven't analyzed the data yet, the rest of the
cohort. Now we have 150 cases, and it looks almost
exactly the same in terms of dividing by quartiles for overall
survival and dividing by time to next treatment.
That is that the highest level do the best and the lowest levels do the worst.
But since we were using the Troplex assay, we could also
look at Trop-2. And this is completely unexpected, and I'm not sure if I
believe it myself or not yet, but if you have high Trop-2, you do poorly
on T-DXd. I'm not sure why that is, but maybe there's some
interaction between Trop-2 and HER2.
But it emphasizes the importance of a selective biomarker.
That is, if you know that you're going to
give one or the other, you want your biomarker to reflect the biology of the
patient's tumor. And if it's high Trop-2, probably is
not only a good idea to give trastuzumab deruxtecan but a bad
idea
because if it's high Trop-2, they won't respond to trastuzumab deruxtecan.
This also bore out in the 150 cases where patients that have the
highest level of Trop-2 do really quite poorly
on
T-DXd. And this is a similar pattern on time to treatment.
Data still to be completed, but just as a glimpse.
So in the prospective study, 6% of the cases have levels of
HER2 that are below the LOD. Those are the true negatives,
and there are patients out there that have no target for HER2.
But not 40% or 20%, but closer to
6% with an analytic assay. And so those are
probably the true nulls. Seventy-one percent of the patients at Yale that were
called IHC equals zero had
analytic measures above the limit of quantification.
That means there may be a fair number of patients out there that should be getting
T-DXd that aren't because they have target present, but by IHC,
we didn't think they did by a subjective test.
The retrospective study showed a difference in median survival, and the
retrospective study also showed a curious result where high Trop-2 are less
likely to benefit from T-DXd.
So the last thing in the last minute or so, I want to talk about next steps.
And the next steps are illustrated in this work that is coming out today.
That's what the QR code is about looking at HER3, another
ADC target for the drug pertuzumab.
And this is work done by Mengni He in my lab.
And what you can see is she looked at a bunch of different targets.
This is not in breast now, this is head and neck.
But a bunch of targets for ADCs, and you can see the distribution,
sometimes almost an inverse relationship, sometimes
clearly a lot of one, but not much of the other at all.
In only a few cases is there any of the other.
In this case, HER3 and HER2. And this is the example of head and
neck
squamous cell carcinoma. And here's an example in non-small cell lung carcinoma.
Right now, we only give T-DXd to HER2 patients that have a mutation in
ERBB2 gene. But you can see that if you look at the HER2
in lung cancers, there's actually quite a dynamic range of
HER2 in lung cancer, and probably more patients would respond than the
2% that are currently given the drug because they have the mutation.
But you can compare these in all these multiple target assays.
And ultimately, where we're going with this is to have-- And these are assays that
we'll have in our lab where you can measure in animals per square millimeter.
We already have the first three. Nectin-4 is right around the corner,
as is cMet. HER3 and FolR1 are a little further out.
But we hope to be able to ultimately triplex them, so you can have instead of just
two markers, you could have a choice of three different ADCs, any
three of the above.
What about in the future? Well, this is our list of future targets that we're
working on. Some of them we're pretty far along.
Some of them we haven't even yet begun.
But I think that you can anticipate a time where there might be 10 or 20
different ADCs in the neoadjuvant setting. Which one are you going to use?
Well, I think that's the need for a selective marker, and I would propose that this
approach can be used to find a selective marker.
This is the group whose work I get to speak for.
My lab group, and highlighted the people who mainly were working on the projects we
talked about,
and my collaborators inside and outside of Yale.
And this is the group
at our most recent holiday party. The work that I mostly showed you was
from Mengni He, Jack Robbins, and Nae Chan.
Thank you.
I don't know if we're going to take-
Any question?
Can I start with a question? Or maybe over there? Yes, of course.
David, this is fantastic work. I really like the quantitative approaches you're
taking to the histology. There was some data presented last year at
ASCO where some folks from Johns Hopkins were characterizing the
internalization, actually, of these proteins versus just what's present
on the surface.
So I'm kind of curious if you have any interpretations on
how internalization of some of these ADC targets
impact your assay.
So that's a great question, because how important is internalization
versus just the target being present?
There's almost no doubt that the target presence is not the only factor.
In fact, for Trop-2, it's clear that even if you have a lot of target present,
there's only still a 30% response rate.
But the internalization is a different variable and much harder to measure.
And if you're going to measure it in a CLIA lab, look what we're doing now.
We're doing IHC. That's grade school stuff.
And so we need to move to more and more sophisticated assays.
And I would bet-- I'm not familiar with that study, but I'll bet internalization is
pretty hard to measure.
Thanks.
Please.
Hi, Anna Berry from Pfizer.
I have a practical question. Your technique looks to be
specific to one instrument. I wonder, do you have an
idea of who has that instrument, and do you have plans to
make it available on multiple instruments?
Thank you for asking that question because I didn't integrate that into the talk.
But there's a lot of the work that I showed, I showed in the beginning that some of
this work is sponsored by Leica Danaher.
And so they're going to build it on their platform with their instrument, with
their juice. We're working on that now, and there's two other companies whose names
I can't mention who are also working toward licensing this technology.
That's amazing.
A follow-up.
When you're saying Leica is working on it, would it work on the instrument somebody
might already own, or would it be a new instrument?
No, it's the Leica bond that's in about 15% of the labs around the
country. It doesn't work on Ventana, the Roche platform, for
various reasons, but it could.
Microphone on my right, please.
Excellent work.
I noted that you looked at percentiles when you're comparing and trying to optimize
for patient therapy. When expression levels can differ by orders of magnitude
between the various TAAs, how do you think about
using percentile for a specific TAA rather than absolute abundance?
That's a great question because we don't know whether absolute abundance is more
important than percentile. That is, it might be you just need a certain number of
molecules to see any kind of response. We don't know that yet.
But we're in three different prospective clinical trials and two retrospective
trials, and hopefully we'll be able to find that answer.
That is: is there a threshold in animals per square millimeter, and is that more
important, or is the percentile in the population more important for matching
patients to drug?
Please.
Thank you for the great talk. I'm Yajun Zhu from UCLA Pathology.
I have a question regarding the timing of the biopsy.
We know that a lot of clinical trials actually starting from their
later lines, like third line or second lines.
So do you think the original tissue, the scoring system, the
biomarker evaluation on the original tissue can representative for
the second-line or third-line tumor status?
Thank you.
So that's a great question.
And the QuantifiHER Trial, which is one of the prospective
trials that's run by the Translational Breast Cancer Research Consortium, is going
to look at that question. That is, which specimen is most important?
Some preliminary data suggests that if you don't have a specimen that's
most proximate to the treatment, you're not going to get the right answer.
That is, looking at the original biopsy and then having a patient metastasize four
years later, you better look at the metastasis because their status may well have
changed in that time.
Thank you. Do you think there is any liquid biopsy
technology that can fill that gap?
Well, someday maybe we'll be able to do it with radiology, but we can't right now.
And so what we've seen is just people doing biopsies of
various-- Our favorite is the liver biopsy and a liver MET because those are easy
to work with. But we can get bone
biopsies to work. They just have to be treated with a very
special decalcification method so that they're not
artifactually destroying the antigen.
Thank you.
Hi, Dr. Ring. Thank you for the fantastic presentation.
My question for you is for those surface marker
about the cleavage or shedding.
It's kind of a lot of happening. So I just wondering, when you select the
antibody for detection for these surface markers, so
do you take into consideration about the epitope this
antibody was targeting?
So that's an excellent question. And just about all diagnostic antibodies are to
the cytoplasmic domain of transmembrane proteins.
And the reason for that is the cytoplasmic domain is not glycosylated, and
glycosylation foils antigen retrieval.
So glycosylation is very non-uniform in terms of antigen retrieval.
So just about every antibody, even though we know the extracellular domain is the
action end, we look at the cytoplasmic domain because that's more stable and more
reproducible to look at.
So you recommend to use the
intracellular domain antibody targeting?
They tend to be more reproducible and more reliable just because
they don't tend to be glycosylated.
You can't glycosylate the intracellular cytoplasmic domain.
It's only the extracellular domain that's glycosylated, and that really plays havoc
on reproducibility for antigen retrieval.
Thank you.
So last question. Yes, please.
Just follow up on that question. Last year, there was some data
presenting even in our DXD
patient, the breast cancer patient that
were treated with the DXD. Even from the 3+
patient, we had responder and non-responder, and some IF data
basically showed that there are some very fine
differences in terms of the expression, which was not detected by
IHC, but by IF, we could see that, that there is a change
in even membranous staining. It's more diffused a little
bit in the non-responder compared to the responder.
So those may be the limitation that we have right now with the
IHC, but I'm wondering if there are methodologies or there
are kind of thoughts to how we can really elaborate on that one.
So it's pretty clear that there's factors other than the target that affect
response to therapy. But what you're talking about, I think, is
heterogeneity or even intra or intercellular heterogeneity,
and that's a really hard challenge.
We're working on it, but it's a really hard challenge. Can fluorescence do that?
Yes, theoretically, we could. And Jack's second aim of his thesis is
to look at heterogeneity and expression on quantitative
fluorescence on the membrane and between cells, since there's the
bystander effect. But we don't have an answer for you
today.
Thank you. Thanks again, Professor Rimmele, for the outstanding talk.
So I think that we can move on
from the pathologist perspective, and we can move on with the
mathematician perspective, Professor Bakolopoulou.
Computational methods and integration of multi-omics data for
predicting ADC activity.
Thank you very much, Barbara, for the introduction and for the
invitation in this very interesting session.
So today, I will discuss
with you the mathematician perspective, and we will
discuss about computational methods, and in particular, how also we can
integrate multi-omics in the context of
ADC activity prediction.
So I don't have any disclosure for this presentation.
So we know that cancer data can span in different kind
of scales, and every scale can bring different kind of aspect for the
disease. So we can actually monitor the mutational
burden and the cancer drivers, the protein activity, and
signaling pathways. We can actually try to model the tumor
microenvironment and its heterogeneity, the tumor localization
and staging, as well as the patient clinical data and
overall the treatment outcomes that we want to identify.
So from all these different scales, what I will focus today, and
after David's talk, is I will focus actually on the tissue,
which is actually histology. Which can be the link between the tissue
structure and the molecular traits that they can actually help us
with the outcomes.
And in a lot of kind of presentations through these days
in the conference, we saw that tumor cell plasticity
and, in general, the genomic instability can actually introduce
some tumor heterogeneity. And this heterogeneity can
be the intertumoral. That means that we can have different kind of
molecular alternations as, for example, the HER2 for the
breast cancer or the EGFR for the lung cancer, and general
microsatellite instability. Or it can also introduce
intratumoral heterogeneity, which actually here we want to
model more or less spatial organization of
the tumoral cells, the composition of the tumoral microenvironment,
and general genetic heterogeneity.
And we know that this heterogeneity, it actually affects a lot the
prognosis of the patients and the therapy response.
So for us, that we are working on the precision medicine, what we are trying to do
is actually deliver the right-- find a way or
create models that they can actually deliver the right
treatment to the right patients in the right time
. And in order to work on this, there are, these days, quite
some translational clinical trials that they are trying
to collect a huge amount of multimodal
data from imaging to multi-omics, to clinical
information. And all this, we are trying actually to build models
that they can associate them or combine them in
understanding also this data in a good way for
clinical outcomes. However, these clinical trials,
even if they are very good, they are a very challenging
context of the AI algorithms, and this is for multiple reasons.
Some of them is that, first of all, we don't have prior knowledge about the drugs
and the biology, especially for the ADC actually
landscape.
We have actually limiting number, usually,
of data and patients that we can use in order to train these models,
and this actually can limit a lot what we can actually extract
from them. And finally, interpretability is something that we are
really looking for when we are talking about models that they can take
some decisions, and this is actually something that is not forgiven when
it comes to AI algorithms, so we need really to work on it.
And one of the first actually proof of concepts or
trials that we have involved, for ADC, it is actually
the DAISY trial, which is actually a phase two
clinical trial on metastatic breast cancer patients that they have been treated
with a TDX drug. And here, we had actually
identified three different cohorts of patients, depending on the
HER2 expression level. And depending on this
expression, the treatment outcomes were very different for these
patients that they have treated with this ADC
drug. And for our actual study, we
focused on the cohort that had an overexpression of the
HER2 in order, more or less, to address the question
or to find in which extent the HER2 spatial
distribution can influence the drug efficacy.
And in order to address this, we worked with the IHC slides
from the DAISY trial. And what we did is that we creating an
fully automatic pipeline on which we can take the
slide, we can actually segment the tissue, and then follow
a quite standard nowadays process on which we can actually
take the tissue,
extract small regions of this tissue, and then use some kind
of deep learning representations in order, more or
less, to extract some information and some
morphological features from these
regions.And what we did actually in this study is that
we went with an unsupervised method in order, more or less,
to cluster this representation that we were getting from the deep
learning models in different clusters and see or study
how these clusters are associated with the clinical outcome and the
distribution in the slide.
So what indeed we noticed is that one of these cluster,
it had actually an association with the treatment resistance,
so we can have quite a significant difference between the two
different
groups of responders. And in order, more or less, to understand the
spatial distribution on the HER2 in this case, we actually tried to
create some more interpretable features in order to understand how the
cells are actually distributed on this region.
And what we did is that we developed an algorithm that it was able to
segment the cells in this IHC and more or
less quantify the numbers of cells that they were inside the cluster of
interest. And what we saw is that more or less the cluster
that we have identified, it had a moderate cell density,
and also it had a very low HER2 staining with respect to the DAB
intensity.
In order to dive a little bit more and understand more of this finding,
pathologists did a manual annotation of this cluster, and they
noticed that they actually consist of fibroblast and immune cells.
So more or less, this finding, they have
ended up to a publication that actually
shows some kind of insights about the HER2 spatial distribution and
how this
contribute to the role of the resistance to the drug.
And since we have this pipeline, we challenge it in two
different trials, again, for ADC, the ICARUS breast and the ICARUS
lung trials, on where again, we tried the same
unsupervised pipeline. This time we had some amelioration on the
computational side. We added some additional features for the
representation of the regions. We also added
information that comes both from
IHC and H&E by integrating types of cells
that we have segmented on the H&E slides and also integrating
prior information coming from the DAB staining that we knew that
it is actually something that is important for the
prediction. And again, you can find these
results in these two papers that they have been published the last two
years.
And you know also in the keynotes in the
morning, one,
in the AI community, we have experience in paradigm shift on the way that we are
doing AI. And in particular in digital pathology, we have
a very big boom of some models that they are
available now for us to use. And these models, they are called
foundation models, and they are models that they have been trained on a huge
pool of data that they are unsupervised.
And their promise is that they can give us actually representations
of regions on the slide that can be actually
useful for a variety of tasks. And most of
these models, actually, they have been trained mainly in a
pool of data that contains H&E slides.
Some of them, they can have also IHC, but the main pool is
H&E. So since we had these advances, we try to see
how we can use them in the pipeline that we had already
developed. But this time working not on the IHC, but on
an H&E slide. So we did exactly the same, but this
time the clustering
was performed on the representations that we got from the H&E
using the UNIC2H
model. And here we have some preliminary results on
which we saw some kind of association with respect to responders
and non-responders. So we had some clusters that they were really popping up with
respect to response. However, in this case, the
type of cells that we had in these clusters, they were much more mixed.
And this is something that we need more or less to interpret a little bit more in
order to have more insights about how we can use this
in this setting.
And what I have discussed to you on the computational side until this
time is focusing on unsupervised techniques.
However, in digital pathology, one of the main methodology that
we are using, it is actually following a supervised setting, which again, we
have the digital pathology slide.
We crop different small regions on the slide.
We use a foundation model or a deep learning model to represent these
patches. And then these representations, they are more or less
somehow aggregated and merged in order to create an
overall representation of the slide and perform the final
prediction. And what is happening here on the aggregator
or on this merged information, most of the times people are
following an attention mechanism on which more or less it can give us
the importance of each of these regions for the final prediction.
And indeed, this attention mechanism, it is used for a lot of studies as
an additional interpretability result in order not
only to have the performance of the model, but also
where the model is focusing on to do this prediction.
However, there are a lot of studies that show that different methods can have
actually different
regions that they are focusing on.
And also these regions, sometimes they cannot give the real regions of interest,
but regions that somehow they are important
for the particular kind of model.
So in our team, we are really working on this,
and
this year we developed the first method that tries to
actually
integrate counterfactual intervention in the attention mechanism,
on where here we are just following the same pipeline as I discussed with you
already. But instead of having only one branch that calculate this
attention of the slide, we have added a second branch on
which we try to perturbate the attention regions in order, more or
less, to... see which of these regions will change
the final prediction. And with that strategy, what
we are actually hoping is that we will have some
more faithful attentions, that they will really focus on the regions of
interest.
So having this,
in the paper, we tested it on variety of
public databases from TCGA, for lung, breast.
And what we saw is that first of all, we can integrate it on a lot of
supervised method, which is very important
from the computational side.
On the same time, we don't really
hurt the performance with respect to the prediction.
And also what we notice is that we have actually predictions that they
are much more targeted and much more important for the
final
score.
So having this method, what we did is that we actually
evaluated, again, in the ICARUS study.
And what we saw is that by taking the attentions that we get from this
method, we were able, again, to have two clusters that we can have
significant difference between responders and non-responders.
And when we were trying to get and understand more what
are these attention focusing on, we
identify that depending on the group of
interest,
some of the attentions, they were really focusing either on neoplastic or
epithelial cells. And these two, they were actually
significantly different between the two different groups.
And on the same time,
and again, all these are some preliminary results that we have
currently, are actually, we monitor and we saw that indeed,
the attentions that we get, they have a bigger impact on the
final prediction, particularly when we are starting
dropping or removing some of these very important regions.
And this is happening on the general kind of
attention region, but also if we take one of the
cluster that has been actually associated with respect to the responder
group. So you can see that our method, the
performance is really
changing if we start
removing a percentage of the attended regions.
Okay. And in my title, actually, I said that I will
discuss about computational methods, but also about multimodal
integration. And indeed, currently, there is actually a
trend in the community on where we are trying to talk about models that they are
more or less general. And with that we mean that
they will be able actually to process on the same time,
multiple type of inputs that comes from images, from
signal, from tabular data, from
multi-omics. And they will be able actually to understand all this
data, integrate them, and perform variety of tasks
for the clinical practice.
However, even if this is something that we are really looking for,
there are a lot of challenges in order to make it work.
The first one is how we can
train them at scale, since that, as we discussed,
sometimes the trials, they can be very limited with respect to data and
amount of patients that we have. How we can do the
verification, because again, interpretability is something that is very
important, and it is not forgiven when it comes to this kind
of models.
They discuss in one of the keynotes today about the
problems of LLMs and so on. And finally,
how we can actually validate and ensure that these models, they can be interesting.
So actually, the tasks that we will validate them, it is also something that we
need to
understand.
So on this axis, last year, we had actually proposed a method
that was able to integrate multiple modalities, and in particular, it was
able to combine histology data with multi-omics
data. And what actually we did is that we used a
kind of deep learning representation, similar than the ones that we
discussed in order to represent the regions of the slide.
We actually merged this with some graph neural networks
in order to take into account the spatial relation of these patches in the
slide. And when it came to the multi-omics
data, then we used some variational autoencoder representations in
order to be able to
represent and encode all the information that comes from all these
different types of data. And for
the mixture of the two, we used the mixture of expert model, which actually can
able to
combine all this information, and on the same time, provide the
weight with respect which actually,
modality is more important for the particular prediction.
And again, since we are working with clinical data,
being also robust with respect to missing modalities is something that is very
important, so we integrated techniques in order to be sure that we will be
able to train and be robust in the case one or more of the modalities
it is missing during the inference.
And again, in the paper, we did quite some
validation with different types of tasks.
We tested with respect to mutation
prediction, survival analysis, and so on.
And what we saw is that our method, it is indeed quite state-of-the-art
and contains a lot of information, and on the same time, it is
able to combine and show which regions are more important for which
task by showing, for example, regions of the slide,
that they are actually correlated with particular kind of gene expressions
and
on all the other panel of data that we're given as an
input.And all this actually,
we are very happy to test them and
use them in one of the big projects that is starting now,
and I think Barbara will give more details later, which is a
European
project that is able to really focus on creating a
score that will be able to predict in a holistic way the ADC
efficacy. And our actual role here in the
project with respect to
this initiative will be actually to create all these kind of computational
methods that they will be able to monitor and encode all
this information that comes from digital pathology,
multiplexing fluorescence, radiology,
genomics and PDOs. And we'll be able
to provide something that will be able to give us more insight
about the ADC resistance. And of course, in
this case, we will focus more on the
interpretability and the efficacy of the generalizability of
the model as well as the modularity in the sense
that since we
are talking about a lot of data, how we can handle missing modalities
will be something that we will really focusing on.
And all this, again, it will be in order to generate a
companion biomarker for ADC prediction and understand more what
is happening with ADC interactions.
So this is actually ongoing work that
it started actually this year, and we are very excited to be part of.
And with that, I would like to conclude my talk for
today. And what I would like to mention from my side as a
biomathematician and engineer is that we have this kind of
paradigm shift with the use of foundation model to be integrated more and
more on our methods, which is something that it is very good from my
perspective because we can give us the opportunity to work with limited
amount of data. We will not have to have so many data to train
them. They will be pre-trained. And also they
give us actually the promise of having
models that they will be able to be generalized in different problems and
tasks. And of course, in our group, we are really working on
interpretability and how we can actually pay, understand, and pay
more attention to find real relations
between data and not causal relations that can
lead to particular prediction. And how we can actually
integrate all this and apply all this with all this kind of merged
modalities that we have on the imaging
perspective, like spatial proteomics, transcriptomics.
It's something that we are really working on together with the
robustness and generalization with respect to
drug discovery and biomarker discovery.
And with that, I would like to thank you and thank also the entire team for all the
work that it does towards
developing methods for cancer treatment.
And if you have any questions, I will be very happy to address.
Thank you.
Questions?
Thanks so much for your excellent talk. I'm Jenny Liu.
I'm a medical oncologist in early phase clinical trials.
I work a lot with ADC sponsors, largely
biotech, and globally there's now over 500
trials that are running- ... ADCs.
One of the challenges is a lot of these companies do not have the
resources to do complex AI, digital
pathology and multi-omics. Is there a way that we
can utilize AI and potentially federated learning
to allow individual sponsors to share their data so
that we can develop predictive and selective biomarker
algorithms for the field overall?
Yeah, very good question, actually.
Indeed, and this is actually one of the limitations that we had
in the days, is that the number of patients that we had, they were very limited, so
we couldn't really do very fancy AI things.
Indeed, I think that trying to combine information
coming from different kind of
sources, it's the key in order to develop more methods.
This can be in the context of federated learning on where you have the
model and you're trying more or less, without having access or
download the data, use the information that you have there.
We can see also other techniques, like for example, we can
try to see if we can share not the initial data, but some
representations of this data that they can be also integrated on
more complex pipelines. But I completely agree with you that
trying to set up in a
very good way a collaborative platform to
combine all this information, it is something that it is needed to
understand more things.
Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you. Thank you very much, Professor Bakolopoulos.
So I think we can move on.
So I'm
going to provide the clinician perspective, of course.
These are my disclosure.
And in terms of clinician perspective, what
I would like to discuss is how we can move from
exploratory to validated biomarkers for a more
precision ADC development in the next future, thanks to the
technologies that we have seen, for example, in the two prior talks.
And to do this, I would like to address three main questions.
The first one is,
given the multidimensional mechanism of action of ADC, if
ADC are targeted therapy, what's the target?
Second question, what are the technologies?
Which technologies we can use and how we can integrate
them? And last question, how we can move
towards
validated biomarkers that can allow a more accurate
ADC selection for each patient, thanks to dedicated
clinical trials.So starting from the
first question, if ADC are targeted therapy, what's the target?
I think that the multidimensional mechanism
of action of ADC
lead us to understand what are the components that are
involved in the ADC response. And of course, I would like
to start from the target antigen, because I think it's the most important
part, at least in the response to the ADC.
And it's the most important part also because preclinical and
clinical study across different type of ADC have shown a
lack of ADC activity if the target is not or low
expressed. I reported here a couple of example for
HER2. T-DXd, trastuzumab deruxtecan, showed
activity in HER2 low models but not in HER2 negative models.
And in the DESI trial, we showed no or very few
T-DXd staining in the tumor sample that were HER2
immunohistochemistry zero.
And on the other side of the slide, you can see a very elegant study that has been
recently published by another group, in which they looked
at the Trop-2 expression and the response to datopotumab
deruxtecan in PDX obtained from patients with
advanced breast cancer. And the authors showed that
Trop-2 negative PDX didn't respond to dato-DXd.
However, if the target is expressed, we have seen that is
very important the way in which we measure the target, and of course we need
more quantitative and reproducible assessment.
But it's also important to measure some other features of the
target that go beyond the target expression.
For example, the target internalization capability.
We have analyzed the Trop-2 internalization capability in the
ICARUS-Lango-1 study that has been published in Cancer Cell a
couple of days ago. And in this study,
we have seen that Trop-2 subcellular localization varied
across the cell lines. And through kinetic uptake assay,
we could observe that cell lines that presented the most rapid
uptake of the ADC were the ones with the greatest
sensitivity to dato-DXd. And we could confirm in some
way these findings in the patient samples.
So we analyzed through an unsupervised clustering algorithm
already shown by Maria before, the tumor sample of these
patients collected at baseline, and we observed a
more uniform cytoplasmic distribution of
Trop-2. That means a low Trop-2 variance, a
low difference between the membrane and the cytoplasm
in the tumor samples of the patients that responded the more to the
treatment. So this finding suggests that the Trop-2
internalization capability can matter in terms of response, at
least to dato-DXd.
And another feature that we have to take
into account is also the intratumor heterogeneity of the target.
And in this trial with
the trastuzumab deruxtecan, we analyzed particularly
the samples of the patient, the HER2 distribution in the sample of
the patients with HER2 positive breast cancer.
And as shown already by Maria before, we found that the HER2
intratumoral distribution can affect the response to the treatment,
and particularly that the prevalence of cluster Cs was found in the
tumor that didn't respond to trastuzumab deruxtecan.
And this cluster zero was characterized by the prevalence of
HER2 zero tumor cell fibroblasts and
immunocells. And some quite similar results have been
recently reported in another study, FASCINATE-n trial, a
neoadjuvant study with another ADC targeting
HER2, trastuzumab rezsitecan. And again, the authors used
computational pathology to evaluate the
intratumor spatial distribution of the target.
So for sure the target antigen matters in the response of the
ADC. But beyond the target abundance, the question is
how much also the tumor microenvironment depending factors can
govern the ADC activity, and particularly the intratumor
distribution and the immunomodulation.
And indeed, we try to address a little bit this question
in ICARUS-Bresto-1 study that we published last year,
in which we analyzed the tumor sample collected at baseline,
but also on treatment from patients with advanced breast
cancer that were treated with patritumab deruxtecan.
And again, with an unsupervised clustering
algorithm, we could analyze the overlapped,
stained and H&E slide in order to
capture the tumor microenvironment architecture
relative to their HER3-positive tumor cells.
And what we found was a prevalence of the cluster zero in
the tumor sample of patient that responded the most to the
treatment. And this cluster zero, as per
pathologist review, was composed of
a moderate number of HER3 positive cells surrounded by
connective tissue with few immunocells and no necrotic areas.
So raising a little bit the hypothesis that this type of
tumor microenvironment architecture could facilitate
the intratumor distribution of the ADC.
And then with the imaging mass cytometry, we also analyzed the on-treatment
samples, and we could find that the on-treatment
samples that presented a higher proportion of
HER3-DXd, so ADC-positive tumor cells,
were the ones that responded more to the treatment with
patritumab deruxtecan. And the bulk arena sequencing analysis
in some way confirmed this finding, because
differential gene expression analysis showed a higher number of
upregulated genes in the HER3-DXd positive tumor as
compared to the HER3-DXd negative tumor.
So this finding in some way suggests that the tumor
microenvironment can affect the intratumor distribution of the
ADC, and finally the tumor cell uptake of the
ADC and the response to the treatment.But also
in ICARUS Breast and ICARUS Lung study, we could
demonstrate that the immunomodulation of the tumor microenvironment
seems to be associated with the response to the treatment.
Indeed, we showed by bulk RNA sequencing the
activation of immuno-related pathways, both in patients treated with
dato-DXd and patients treated with HER3-DXd.
And in the ICARUS Lung 1 study also, we've shown
a significant improvement of some
specific immunocells in the patients that responded to the treatment by
imaging mass cytometry.
So I would say the target antigen for sure it matters, but maybe there
is also a role of the tumor microenvironment.
And now what about the payload? And particularly, what about the tumor histology
and genomic characteristics that can affect the payload
activity?
I have reported in the slide some example.
Of course, there are many others. But the first example comes
from the TOP1 mutation, because there are a number of
study that are starting to show that the presence of
TOP1 mutation can be associated with the resistance to
ADC with the topoisomerase 1 inhibitor payload.
We have to take into account that this mutation are quite rare.
There are also some evidence about the loss of
SLUFN11 in the tumor samples that can be resistant to
ADC with the topoisomerase 1 inhibitor payload.
And indeed, we demonstrated this also in the ICARUS
Lung 1 study, in which we showed
that
the tumor of the patients that responded to the treatment
presented a higher proportion of SLUFN11 positive
tumor cells. And we finding in preclinical model
that indeed, when we selectively
inactivated SLUFN11 in cell lines that were
highly sensitive to dato-DXd, we observed a markedly
reduction in the sensitivity in the cytotoxic response to the
treatment. And finally, there is a growing
number of study, I would say, that are looking also at the ATP
binding cassette, so the flux transporter of the
payload,
with some evidence on the possible association with the resistance to the
payload. Here an example on the ABCC1
overexpression that seems to be associated with resistance to
DXd.
So with all these findings in mind, I think
that the definition of ADC as a potential
target expression is a little bit challenged.
And what I would like to think and to conceptualize is more that
the ADC can be potentially considered as a tumor
ecosystem targeting therapy, in which the biomarkers
have to consider not only the target expression, internalization
capability, but also the tumor microenvironment characteristic, and
also the payload fate.
And so if we want to capture, to embrace this
complexity, I think that we need to integrate different tools and
technology in order to capture the multiple possible
determinants of the response to the ADC.
And so what are the technologies that we can take into account?
I think that the two prior talks have really clarified
what is the potential of the quantitative assay, but also
of the computational pathology to obtain a more
comprehensive target antigen characterization, but also to
obtain a more comprehensive characterization of the ADC
pharmacodynamic within the tumor and the tumor microenvironment.
However, I would like also to spend some words on the molecular nuclear
imaging and CTC because I believe that there is some
room for these technologies, particularly in the prediction of
response to this drug.
So molecular nuclear imaging is a combination of imaging
technology and molecular biology, and ZEPHIR has been a sort
of proof of concept study about the role of molecular nuclear
imaging in the ADC field. In this study, the
authors elegantly showed that 89 zirconium
trastuzumab PET scan could first of
all capture their true heterogeneity across the different tumor
sites and predicted the response to the ADC that in this case was
TDM1. And indeed, they showed a negative
predictive value of 84% that raised to
100% if the HER2 PET
scan was combined with FDG PET scan.
And since that study, there are now multiple
study that are evaluating different antibody with different
radiotracer in order to capture the target heterogeneity across
the different tumor sites and predict the response to the
ADC. In this slide, I have reported only some example
of
ongoing study that are evaluating new radiotracer for
HER2, Trop-2, and Nectin-4 and trying to
understand what is the potential of this technology to predict the
response to the ADC.
But I think that another evolution of the molecular imaging that can be
particularly interesting in the ADC field is also the possibility of
radiolabeling not only the naked antibody but also the
ADC in order to investigate in vivo the ADC distribution
across the different tumor sites.
And I have reported here a couple of example, a
preclinical study that showed a successfully radiolabeling of
sagituzumab govitican, but particularly this ongoing
study, very interesting ongoing study that is using 89
zirconium patritumab deruxtecan in order to
capture the HER3 expression across the different
tumor sites, and particularly also the ADC distribution
across the different localization.And then
also the CTC. As I mentioned before, I think that the
CTC can provide a multidimensional
measurement that can be particularly useful in the ADC field.
And there are already some studies that have started to investigate,
to interrogate the role of the CTC in the ADC
field. In ICARUS Bresto-1 study, so again in patients treated
with patritumab deruxtecan for metastatic breast cancer,
we characterized the ER3 positive CTC by
FACS in order to understand if we could detect the
ER3 positive CTC, first of all, and also to understand if the
ER3 positive CTC could predict the response to the treatment.
This is a very small sample size. However, we couldn't find any
differences between the responders and no responders to the treatment.
And on the other side of the slide, you can see also that there is another
study that has recently characterized Trop-2 and
positive and HER2 positive CTC in patients treated with the antibody drug
conjugates. Again, in order to capture the target
heterogeneity and predict the response to the ADC.
And here the author could demonstrate a limited concordance
between the target expression on the CTC and on the tumor
biopsy, and also a poor association with the clinical
response. So some, I would say, first negative
results, but I think that there is still some room for
the CTC in the ADC field, and particularly with the new
technologies that can characterize
the single CTC by integrating genomic,
transcriptomic, and proteomic, and can potentially provide a sort of
real-time ADC pharmacodynamic biomarker in which
we can measure directly the target engagement, the DNA
damage response, and the gene expression modulation.
So coming back to our framework for the precision medicine
development of the ADC, we have seen there are several
technologies that we can consider, that we can take into
account.
But the question is also how we can integrate all this
technology and select the most appropriate technology,
integrating them in order to obtain composite biomarker
to better predict the response to the ADC.
And I think that one of the model proposed before by Maria,
that is the multimodal Castomics developed by Centrale
Supelec, is only one among many other that are available
and that are able to integrate
histopathology images, but also multi-omics
data in order to have a more comprehensive characterization of the
tumor and potentially the potential of
better predicting the response to this type of treatment.
But beyond the definition of this composite biomarker,
I think that we have also to move forward with a validation of the
biomarker.
The study that I have shown so far are study that are very limited
exploratory trial, so with a very limited sample
size, for the majority are retrospective, and most of
them rely on a multidimensional tumor feature.
So we need more prospective study that can incorporate
composite biomarker in patients treated with ADC.
And this is, I think, the mandatory step in order to arrive, to
provide, to implement this biomarker in the clinical practice,
and finally, to select the most accurate ADC for each
patient.
So the final question is, which kind of study design we can
consider to move forward from the exploratory to the
validated biomarker? I think that if we want to
translate this tumor ecosystem
targeted therapy paradigm that I have
considered before into multidimensional biomarker, we have
to rely on three main study design.
First of all, to include more longitudinal tumor biopsy and
liquid biopsy in early phase trial with ADC,
because we need to collect very early in the ADC development,
translational insights, and particularly on the ADC
pharmacodynamic that can inform further
study in which we can integrate with the multidimensional
model different type of data, and finally
obtain through machine learning model, composite predictive
signature that can be used for selecting
patient to receive a specific ADC in platform
study for a precision enrollment.
That means allocate the patient to receive the ADC
according to this composite biomarker.
And I think that this kind of framework can finally lead to have
ADC that are more personalized therapy, to have more rational
combination of ADC with other therapy, immunotherapy, targeted
therapy, and finally, to enhance the efficacy and the safety of this
compound.
So in terms of early clinical trials with the
longitudinal biopsy, I think that there are at least some
study that have demonstrated the value of this kind of approach
that have
enriched our knowledge in terms of understanding some
potential biomarker that are related to the response of the
ADC. Some of the trial that I cited before, but also, for
example, TOT-HER3 study of the SALTI group that
looked at the patients treated with the TRDX-T in
a window of opportunity study with longitudinal
biopsy.But there are also already some studies that
are starting to consider multidimensional
model, multidimensional framework,
in which different kind of data are integrated in
order to predict the response to the ADC.
For example, this multimodal framework that is proposed
in the FASCINATE and trial published last year in "Cancer
Cell." There is also this ADC treatment response
score that is based on a multivariate gene expression
analysis that concerns the target expression, but also the
tumor proliferation and the tumor adhesion.
And I think that another important study in this setting is the OASIS
study that we are conducting Europe that is funded by a
European grant. And this is a multiparametric
approach that wants to define what are the
key components of the response, resistance, and
toxicity of the ADC by integrating advanced
molecular nuclear imaging, but also tumor proteomic,
genomic, transcriptomic, CTC patient-derived
organoids to finally have a multi-omic
prediction score that can support the clinician in the
future to select the most appropriate ADC for each patient.
This study is already recruiting in the first part, that is
the prospective and the retrospective part across the different
countries in Europe. And finally, there are already some
study that have started to include
patient according to specific biomarker to
receive a given ADC or another one.
One example is ADC MATCH study that is
currently ongoing, in which the patient are selected to receive, for
example, trastuzumab deruxtecan, sacituzumab govitecan, and fortumab
vedotin, according to a
proteomic and transcriptomic profiling of the tumor.
And we have figured out to
use this kind of approach also in the OASIS part two, in which the
patient will be enrolled to receive a specific ADC
according to the results of the composite biomarker that we will generate
in the part one.
So in conclusion, I think that ADC are
likely to act as more tumor ecosystem targeting therapy
rather than simple targeted therapy with an activity that is
driven, of course, by the target, but
also by multidimensional biological determinants that are
also related to the tumor histology genomic characteristics, but also
to the tumor microenvironment. The integration of advanced
technologies is essential to capture this complexity
and identify actionable biomarker for a more
ADC precision medicine development.
And I think that we need also dedicated clinical trials to
validate this multidimensional biomarker and enable, in the
future, a real-time patient ADC matching.
And with this, I would like to thank all the people, all the
colleague that work on the OASIS program, and also
all my colleagues that work in the different ADC program at
Gustave Roussy. And thank you very much for your attention.
Any question?
Thank you for your great presentation.
So my question is how long does it take to
make this multidimensional biomarker analysis
before deciding which kind of treatment
it will be better to give to each patient?
Because the patient is there and is waiting for the
treatment.
Thank you for this question, and this is one of
the major point of discussion when we
built this OASIS program, because
we truly believe that the possibility to have a biomarker that can
be used in real time is one of the major point.
So what we
are considering are technologies that can be performed in real
time. So technologies such as tumor
genomic and transcriptomic profiling and proteomic profiling is
something that
in this program we are currently trying to perform in about three,
four weeks. So if we can keep this kind of
timeframe, I think that in the future is something that is feasible.
The question is more about the scalability of this kind of approach.
And what
I mean is in the next future, of course, not all the
centers in the world will be able to provide this type of approach
to all the patients. And this is something that we have to think about.
So to understand how we can create networks,
collaboration among main centers and
a sort of hub which network
hospitals, satellite hospitals can eventually send the
samples and have the response in a time that
is useful for the patients to be selected for the right
treatment.
Thank you for your great presentation.
So right now, the clinical trial on treatment
biopsy tend to be more and more liquid biopsy, but not tissue
biopsy. Given the concordance of the
liquid biopsy and the relative poor
and then the limitlimitation of the LOD.
So
from clinical perspective, I'm just wondering,
how can we learn from the disease progress or
resistance mechanism?
Yeah, that's a very good question.
So
in Gustavo Rossi, we have conducted, and we are still conducting
several study with the on-treatment biopsy, but I'm not
saying that we can propose on-treatment biopsy to all our patients,
in the future and particularly in clinical practice.
I believe that the on-treatment biopsy can be particularly
useful in early phase trial with a new
compound in order to understand the pharmacodynamic of the
drug, and particularly the interaction with the tumor and the tumor
microenvironment. As far as concern to move this
evidence of the on-treatment biopsy to the clinical practice,
I really believe that in the
future, this type of
multimodal framework can really pick up the important
information that we have and that can be transferred
into a biomarker that can be applied to the clinical practice.
I will explain myself a little more.
There are some biomarkers that are present on the on-treatment
biopsy that potentially can be found in the CTC in the
future if we arrive to develop CTC that
become a sort of pharmacodynamic biomarker.
If we are able to understand in the CTC, if the ADC has been
internalized, the target has been engaged, there is a response
of the CTC to the treatment. So I think that the on-treatment
tumor biopsy can be easily
replaced in the future, potentially replaced in the future.
I'm not sure that is going to be easy.
Potentially replaced in the future by liquid biopsy, not only
ctDNA, but also CTC.
Hi.
One more very practical question.
These things sound amazing, and I can't wait to get my hands on all these
tools. However, in the near future,
when we do have the very old-fashioned, outdated IHC,
should we be approaching that differently rather than just
looking at H-score? Should we look at size of the
tumor foci? Obviously, we should look at the
microenvironment, but should we look at size of the foci?
Should we look at the total amount of staining in the entire tumor
mass, not just the tumor cells? Is there a
way for us to improve on just doing H-score for evaluation of
ADC samples?
Okay. I think that Professor Rim is the most appropriate
speaker to address this question.
So that's a great question. When you take a standard
biopsy,
you're probably looking at 0.01% of the tumor.
And so it's not going to be representative, and I don't think much is
gained by changing what we do with an H-score.
I'm anxiously watching what happens with circulating
free DNA or circulating methods,
because that may be more representative than the small amount we get in tumors.
Okay.
If I can ask a question as well.
Of course.
What's your vision for how these multimodal markers get into a CLIA
lab?
Say again.
What's your vision for how these multimodal markers get into a
lab where they have to pass all the certifications that are
required for reproducibility?
Yes. This is another tough point that we have to consider in
our Oasis program or in other programs that are currently
ongoing with the similar approach.
This is a question that we have not faced yet, but
we are going to face hopefully in the future if this model
finally demonstrated to be
interesting to select the patient.
And this is another aspect of the scalability that I was mentioning
before. We have to understand how this kind of
approach and this kind of model can be reproduced in
other hospital and in other
countries. This is a further step of
Oasis that we are not facing yet.
Thank you.
So,
I think that
we don't have any more question. So I would like to thank
this outstanding panel for the very
impressive, I would say, presentation.
Thank you very much and enjoy the rest of the meeting.